good morning Hank it's Wednesday the day
that students at Euro beach high school
gave me a shirt with all the things I
love on it Hank while you've been
sitting in your fancy new house in
Missoula Montana I've been traveling the
country collecting awesome t-shirts and
also failing to acquire a camcorder but
I'm working on that Hank I'm here at the
Biltmore Hotel in Miami Florida you know
what they give you when you check into
this hotel boos here's to you my friend
I guess we aren't really friends we're
brothers but will we be brothers after I
punish you as you no doubt noticed your
video yesterday was 4 minutes and 16
seconds long now I bet you have some
weird semantic argument for why you
shouldn't be punished and I'm going to
get that weird semantic argument from
you but first I want to show you my
shopping bag I mean Hank I'm so excited
about what I'm about to show you that I
have to do my happy dance wall holding
my macbook with the iSight camera hah
hah hah hah hah hah the camera froze on
a funny face let's see that face again
please thank you MacBook iSight camera
you are why I'm buying a camcorder
tomorrow okay but anyway before we talk
about punishment I got to show you
what's in the bag by the way this does
have to do with the plot of Paper Towns
but does not represent any kind of
spoiler I promise do you know what that
is Hank that is every item that Lacey
and Ben and Q and radar pick up at their
first stop at the BP including the Nerds
I mean Hanks something that existed only
in my imagination now exists on my hotel
bed in Miami Florida and all thanks to
nerdfighters at Vero Beach High School I
mean that's it Hank that's the whole
thumb attic structure of Paper Towns on
my hotel bed in the form of beef jerky
snack crackers and fictional go-fast
bars by the way Hank they didn't just
get any kind of nerds they got rainbow
nerds god I love rainbows and god I love
nerdfighters they're just so awesome so
Hank that's the good news nerdfighters
are awesome the bad news your video was
4 minutes and 16 seconds long it did not
contain a montage that is clearly
against the rules now I'm going to call
you and find out what your ridiculous
justification for making a video over
four minutes is
oh hello Hank it's your brother John
this is being recorded for an internet
video show I do called nerdfighters or
vlogbrothers or Brotherhood 2.1 I happen
to notice that your video yesterday was
4 minutes and 16 seconds long your
justification for making a 4 minute and
16 seconds I understand it is that the
video portion of the video did not last
4 minutes and 16 seconds and ergo the
video as a video as a visual phenomenon
was shorter than four minutes mm-hmm
okay well I'm just going to let the
nerdfighters vote on whether or not they
agree with you oh did I tell you by the
way that that that one of the one of the
publicists that penguin said that you
were my Sarah Palin because they said
that you bring out the base like you get
people motivated and excited and then
I'm the like I'm the like serious old
one I'm the one I'm the one who's like
my friends I think that we should read
books alright I gotta turn off that I'm
going to turn off the iSight camera here
but Hank I'll see you tomorrow and I'll
continue talking to you right now okay
nerdfighters vote for whether you think
Hank should be punished up to see you
tonight in Miami tomorrow in Orlando or
on Friday in Naperville Illinois